here's a story from Bloomberg Tesla
Engineers visit Twitter office to review
code for Musk
well there you go I mean that's the news
this is huge so
um
I I think this is why vajagada was
crying when the news broke that Elon was
buying the platform because I wonder
who's going to prison
well I think wow people should certainly
be held accountable and face serious
consequences for what Twitter did
especially during the 2020 election uh
you know leading up to the 2020 election
when they censored the hunter Biden
story and they started banning all the
conservative counts and out of nowhere
they banned political advertising
without giving people really much of a
heads up and there should be some real
life consequences for this Facebook by
the way has just been ordered to pay
24.7 million dollars to the state of
Washington because they didn't release
all the information behind their
political advertisements now imagine
what we're going to see if we're going
to actually see anything because again
at the end of the day we also have to
start thinking about this this way this
is Elon musk's new product will he
release information that makes this
product look bad that's another question
I think we should be asking ourselves it
could make it look good look because
it's all you're also looking at the
regime change if Elon comes in right now
and says just right at the gate
so when they testified before Congress
about these three things they lied
here's the proof in their code I wonder
who then you know if they I don't know
if they testified under oath or whatever
probably not but that'll be huge make
Twitter look as bad as possible and
that's that's the right move you know
why because then if in two years you
only make it look a little bit better it
looks a lot better you know what I mean
when when uh when Chairman Mao died in
1976
um the party the Chinese Communist Party
of course they have their new emperor
now but at the time they realized they
had to CR they had to kind of find a way
to maintain the legitimacy of the party
in the face of the cultural revolution
and 15 million people have been killed
every school every University in the
entire country shut down families turned
against family it's abject chaos going
on across the entire country so they
have to find some way to say okay we can
still be in power we have to maintain
the brand but we have to separate from
this so what do they do they blamed it
on his wife
and three of her friends they call him
the gang of four they arrested the wife
then she commits suicide in prison
um and and then Deng Xiaoping the party
go off and and say well now that we've
taken care of that everything's fine
take a look at this and the story they
say Twitter's Engineers can no longer
make changes to code AS of noon in uh
San Francisco with people wow that's
part of an effort to ensure that nothing
about the product changes ahead of the
deal closing so the people who declined
to be named come on they had months to
figure out how to cover their tracks and
and bury the evidence right they
probably called in Hillary Clinton be
like Hillary Clinton you got experience
with this matter please bring the bleach
please or bring the hard drive please I
mean this is this is bring the rag if
Sheamus is listening we got one for you
Elon is going to buy the platform and
and then Vijaya got if it's crying what
do we do they're gonna get the evidence
and then they hear a doorbell ring and
they open the door and it's Hillary
Clinton with like six hammers in her
belt and she's like let's go and
sunglasses smashing everything with
hammers uh and for those who don't know
it's because the Clinton campaign
smashed their phones with hammers
thinking that would actually stop
someone from collecting the data but you
know and when she was asked at one point
about wiping her server her legal email
server that she had in her bathroom she
said was in my bathroom yeah yeah she
said right you mean like with a rag yes
and then I love when NBC News Trump said
she she acid washed her server it was
like fact check false Hillary Clinton
did not use a corrosive wait you
remember how they called the guy on
Reddit right yeah yeah yeah he's
bragging about it well no no he wasn't
just bragging he didn't know how to do
it he went and he said how do I remove a
very very VIP from some emails
and I'd also like to point out that
yesterday was the six year anniversary
of Hillary Clinton's happy birthday to
the Future president yes uh the tweet
that will forever live in infamy one of
the greatest tweets ever in my opinion
I'd just like to sometimes Play that
video where she's sitting in the chair
and she's like you can be the candidate
you can be the nominee and it can be
stolen from you and then I'm just like
uh see well she doubled down on those uh
elect being an election denier a couple
days ago she said that right-wing
extremists are already starting to steal
the 2024 election and you know I just
got subpoenaed and went through a year
and a half of you know health or
questioning the legitimacy of the 2020
election with evidence backing it up you
know is a republican Congress going to
subpoena Hillary Clinton for sowing
distrust in the 2024 election already so
you know the wicked witch is refusing
but by the way look listen to these
these phrases that we're using now
sowing distrust raising questions
none of there's no law backing up any of
these things there's this isn't a legal
basis the legal basis in the United
States is something called freedom of
speech did you see the Veritas that's
where the sludge comes from you see the
project Veritas release that said uh
yeah they're tracking misinformation as
an election crime and they Define it as
accidental like false information that's
a mistake so it's like I mean there used
to be an old joke and I'm not going to
say it but the this whole joke that you
know they would say Republic vote on and
then they would use a different day of
the week than election day or you could
change it as a Democrats vote on a
different you see what I'm saying yeah
and that would be this idea
got arrested for that there was a there
was a guy who was well we just saw uh
over over a draft Meme and he was
arrested and charged claiming you know
this this meme campaign that was done in
2016 it was I believe it started on
4chan and um got the guy's name at the
top of my head
but uh his real name as a Twitter name
and he was arrested for creating a meme
saying that Hillary Clinton wanted to
draft our daughters
and then meanwhile like you said like
you mentioned at the beginning of the
show you have you know fetterman that's
oh you're running lies and lies and lies
no it's probably packs well the packs
that are aligned with Federal that are
heavily funded by the Democrat Party I
did see a commercial where he said I
approved this message right so these
people Douglas these yeah Douglas Mackey
he's got a great uh legal defense fund
if you guys want to check it out
um just Google his name uh I'm sure you
guys can find that but uh it's horrible
what's happening to but John fetterman
can run these ads that are are knowingly
lies and they put millions of dollars
behind them and John fetterman like you
said we'll probably just get a little
fine or a slap on the wrist but Douglas
Mackey has a draft Meme and now he's
facing prison time a draft all right
right you know and so it's uh it's just
BS and and it's wrong and so I think
that that whoever the next Republican
president is I hope it's I believe it's
going to be Donald J Trump I would like
to see him pardon Douglas Mackey for
this and uh we can't say once I agree
with Megan Kelly by the way on on her
take on the primary well that's about
DeSantis uh just her take on where the
Republican party is the Republican base
and then she was in this um interview
with I think it was Dave Rubin and he
was asking her do you think Santa's
going to get it do you think Trump's
going to get it and she said it's it's
just going to be trumping right there's
no question saw that she and I think
he's right and then Trump posted it on
true social and now it's gone like
nuclear that's right yeah basically
saying she said uh uh DeSantis is is
made by Trump basically everybody knows
that DeSantis knows it DeSantis needs
Trump his endorsement so there's no way
he runs against them it's true and you
know it's not like I mean does Santa's
goes viral on Twitter but at the end of
the day he doesn't have the people's
support across the country only six
percent of Rhonda Santos's donations
come from small dollar donors he's got
500 Mega donors including you know
Chicago billionaire Ken Griffin that has
given them like 140 million bucks and so
like we need a president for the people
not by Wall Street we talked about when
Trump said to lock up the journalist
until they give up their sources
and uh you you know it's it's a very bad
thing it's kind of scary but everyone
laughs and cheers about it Trump
supporters are happy I just think people
need to realize these these Democrats
most of the influential figures here's
here's let me slow down
on the left prominent political figures
are journalists on the right prominent
political figures are just us yeah like
random disparate voices some work some
are Consultants some are politicians
some work in media some are journalists
but the left loudest voices are like
activists and journalists Maggie
haverman right Rachel maddowell Taylor
so when Trump says take the person who's
writing and lock him up and then they
soon are going to find out they're going
to be someone's boyfriend they'll Spill
the Beans who in this case he by the way
would be Josh gerstein from Politico but
people cheer for this and the Democrats
are like oh it's so horrifying and I'm
like yeah you know the thing is regular
Americans despise the media so much and
this poll after poll shows it that you
are not earning any favors by in by
coming after Trump for this uh Greg
gianforte body slammed a journalist when
he was running for congress
um and they said oh he's going to lose
this is terrible this is terrible not
only did he win the Congressional race
he's now the governor of Montana
I mean so yeah yeah
because people really surprised just
read the room it's kind of scary I don't
like it but uh the media is such
despicable evil garbage I mean just do
this there's other ways to find that
leaker than that a lot sure sure there's
better ways to finally yeah after uh
Trump learn about coloring the water I
mean I'm surprised art of four stuff but
after the Federman Oz debate Google
search Dr Oz all hit pieces every single
one of them and I'm just like this is
this is insane I even saw someone
pointing out that if you go to YouTube
it's actually hard to find the full
debate that is it is unless you go to
the uh official YouTube channel of the
news organization that did it so I think
they they win against all the other
channels
a lot of videos what if you said it by
length and say like can't you do like 20
minutes plus or something I haven't seen
it anywhere and I've heard those videos
be deleted wow so you're talking about
the Google searches uh only being
negative odd stories but or professors
during during that uh debate right after
that debate Google searches for how do I
change my vote we're off the charts in
Pennsylvania so the people watch that
debate they're like look they lied to me
they said John fetterman had some sort
of functioning brain it was evident that
he didn't and so now the people that you
know maybe they voted for him early they
want to vote for Dr imagine being Connor
lamb right now another thing that you
lost at this guy all right you know
which keep in mind the Democrat and this
this is this is why keep in mind the
relationship between Democrats and media
has always been like this right they
were able to hide up the fact that FDR
couldn't walk for years they would prop
him up but the point about Fetter men
that I want to make is this he had that
stroke a week before the primary this
was not recent because before they kept
it a secret and at one point he was
posting videos as if he was in these
rallies and holding events while he was
in the hospital nobody in media called
him out on this and thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there